Oh what is going on you two timidly
everybody seems to talk about kids who
are growing up way too fast but let me
get the city of La you seem to learn and
see a lot of interesting things for
example you have any idea how many
hipsters are giving $1 to because I
thought they were homeless get out
take this how dare you I am NOT homeless
I am thrift shop chic tough buddy big in
LA is actually the opposite it's more
old people trying to get their youth on
now personally I'm not trying to cramp
your style
if you old as hell and you try to get
Joe euthanasia owned then go ahead and
do it do you think I'm doing this right
then go ahead but there are boundaries
there are a few things that you should
know to realize that you are too old for
certain things
so y'all like know what it is LG up at
me let's get an ex-cop you're too old
for climbing if your titties look like
pancakes on a hangnail my god I can
ashes out enough if your titties look
like a deflated balloon you need to take
the precautionary measures to make sure
that that [ __ ] does not slip out take
them down
wrap them up I don't care but yo sure
mamas are no longer puppies the old man
GS dogs and they need to be let down now
only women going out clubbing the [ __ ]
that's not a problem
hell no why because every now then
sometimes women need to go to a club to
release the everyday pressures of the
life on that dance floor and now ain't
nothing but a number right but age and
gravity has affected certain parts of
your body now true story I was at a club
a few years back and there was a lady in
her upper 50s getting a groove on all
the dance flow problem was when she was
on the dance low she was doing this move
let's do that [ __ ] slow motion
here's some math for y'all Jax boobs
plus flappity knees equals scarred for
life my god that babies titty popped out
like an old-ass leather wallet that's
famous I cannot get out my hand for the
rest of my life there was so much areola
on that titty [ __ ] look like a melted
Reese's Cup old-ass man get your ass out
the club there is no reason for a 60 or
70 old man to be in a club with women
half their age pervert there's a huge
difference between all the women that go
clubbing and older guys to do the same
ladies sometimes just like to go
clubbing to dance with their girlfriends
no dirty thoughts just to let loose and
have some fun Hank oh hey the only big
old s do wanna let loose in the club is
his wrinkly ass dick and ain't nobody
got time for that
do you know what old men do after the
done creeping you out at the club all
night they go back home and they're not
all that homeys about [ __ ] that they did
maybe you should have been there
yesterday when I was at the club grab a
ball this female right here Oh word
charlie that's what you did well what's
he look like
I'll use all so you say you'd open okay
[ __ ] like cheer like hell I pose you
know the bit like teeth punch a block
the student string away and quit
creeping people out do you have any idea
how uncomfortable you look in that scene
with your Hawaii shirt tucked into your
khakis look I defend you want to feel
young again because when you were
younger you were the [ __ ] but reality
check you're all looking if your balls
sweet any lowers it was great across the
dance floor look I hate telling people
to act the age because it's so
subjective what does that even mean but
there is a certain amount of etiquette
and self-awareness that comes along with
age that is being forgot tape up your
kids suck your balls up and accept the
fact that you're getting a little older
look I'll just say don't get mad at me
when you coochie pop it on the floor and
your coochie literally pops off get it
grandma get this [ __ ] I'm doing it oh my
god you can't believe everything
look sex baby don't say nothing they all
I can say
Oh
I really
I see I remember somebody said you can't
sneeze dries open it's impossible eyes
oh yeah no I don't do that or pops out
dude I've never fainted this one-handed
does not